jours de grève pour les salariés du site
sanofi de val de reuil
depuis ce matin très tôt quatre heures
pour les premiers arrivants ils veulent
faire entendre leurs revendications à
savoir une amélioration de leurs
conditions de travail une augmentation
de salaire ainsi qu'une prime de 2000
euros pour tous les salariés qui ont
travaillé depuis le début de la crise
sanitaire
on écoute de représentants syndicaux on
est dehors pour pour stopper la
politique sociale de l'entreprise
ça fait dix ans qu'on a plus de
collective alors que l'entreprise fait
des bénéfices en croissance
ça fait 26 année consécutive que sanofi
augmente ses dividendes pour les
actionnaires
on a versé 4 milliards de dividendes
cette année 4 milliards
c'est 50% de nos bénéfices qui part
directement pour nos actionnaires et
nous pour les salariés pour a fait + 20
% on est venu défendre la santé publique
on nous offre une gourde
ce n'est pas une image une vraie gourdes
c'est la seule récompense qu'on a ça ça
nous met hors de nous c'est indécent
tout en sachant qu'à l'heure
d'aujourd'hui on est en guerre contre
une pandémie et la problématique c'est
que on n'a aucune vision aucune vision
tout en sachant que l'on travaille pour
un site industriel le fleuron de
l'industrie française sur le vaccin mais
on n'a aucune perspective de sortie de
haut niveau des vagues sans surtout du
profil des salariés qui ont reçu un
soutien de taille celui de françois
ruffin le député de la france en
soumises de la somme a fait le
déplacement depuis paris pour venir à la
rencontre des salariés
et comme il se dit choqué par la
situation et l'annoncent notamment de la
suppression de 400 postes dans les
secteurs du développement et de la
recherche
comment ça se fait que l'état laisse
faire comment ça se fait que l'état est
complice de ça comment ça se fait que
l'état approuve ça
serge weinberg directeur président de
sanofi je vois régime remettre la légion
d'honneur l'an dernier pour moi ce que
j'interroge centralement si aujourd'hui
la complicité de l'état français avec la
politique de sanofi une grève qui
devrait se poursuivre dans les jours
dans les semaines à venir puisque les
syndicalistes préviennent ils ne
s'arrêteront pas avant d'avoir obtenu
gain de cause